jean frédéric poisson georges kiejman au
beach bonjour à tous les deux
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france notamment pour
revenir sur l'une des actualités fortes
de ces dernières heures la situation en
guadeloupe des hommes du raid du gign
envoyés en renfort ce week end pour
faire face aux émeutiers une situation
normale pour yannick jadot le candidat
europe écologie les verts à la
présidentielle regarder et puis on en
parle après
ces terribles et intolérable et il est
normal que l'état engage des forces pour
rétablir la paix en guadeloupe alors la
réponse à cette crise est d'abord la
fermeté face à des minorités pour
gabriel attal le porte parole du
gouvernement vous rejoignez cette
stratégie jean frédéric poisson
je pense que il est difficile de
négocier ou d'entamer un dialogue
lorsque les conditions de l'ordre sont
pas rétablies ne sont pas réunies et je
comprends que lorsque on assiste à des
troubles à l'ordre public de la violence
que l'on constate sur nos écrans et bien
que l'état il veut rétablir de l'euro
public ça me paraît normal maintenant la
question c'est comment en est on arrivé
là et je constate que il ya comme à
l'occasion du mouvement des idées jaune
il ya trois ans en france le
gouvernement a décidé de doubler sa
stratégie de pourrissement par une
stratégie de discrédit
essaye de faire comprendre au
métropolite a que lorsque les
revendications qui sont portées par les
protestataires sont sont illégitimes
certaines d'entre elles sont un peu un
peu barreaux on va dire mais beaucoup
d'entre elles devraient au moins faire
l'objet d'un dialogue et la réponse
c'est surpris d'entendre elie domota
lors je n'ai pas vérifié je sais pas si
c'est vrai mais dire partout personne ne
lui répond qu'il ne rencontre personne
visiblement préfet ne lui répond pas
quand ils posent des questions donc
verbal ne sais pas des cellules ne font
pas
donc cette espèce de d'escale de la
violence est quelque chose de délétère
pour l'idée que l'état il doit y mettre
fin ne serait ce que pour commencer les
discussions
ça ne paraît pas anormale la question et
après la violence après le
rétablissement parlant de l'europe nick
quoi donc si on y va pour établir nord
il faut prendre l'engagement en même
temps que les discussions vont commencer
quel que soit par ailleurs le caractère
pertinent des demandes qui sont forme de
gouvernement georges que ce soit
djokovic la fermeté d'abord avant le
dialogue face à aux minorités
non je ne crois pas moi je refuse de
tomber dans la manipulation organisée
par le gouvernement est porté dans les
médias par monsieur gabriel attal et que
ressemble un peu à ce qui s'est fait
avec le gilet jaune en bien évidemment
je suis d'accord avec monsieur poisson
il faut
l'état doit remettre l'ordre face aux
émeutiers mais il faut bien se rendre
compte que dans par rapport à ce qui se
passe on va l'oublier 3 il ya trois
éléments vous avez effectivement d'un
côté et des émeutiers mais ils sont
toujours là quand il ya des révoltes et
qui en profite et qui pis est bon bien
évidemment eux il faut mettre de l'ordre
c'est évident mais le gouvernement
essaie de faire passer l'ensemble des
revendications portées par les citoyens
guadeloupéens sur ses métiers alors que
ce qu'on l'envoie là ressemble
étonnamment à ce qu'on a vu en 2009 lors
des grèves de l'ong de 2009 où il y eu
aussi des barrages s'étaient déjà elie
domota qui était secrétaire général de
l'union générale des travailleurs de
guadeloupe et les revendications étaient
étonnamment les mêmes que maintenant
c'est à dire que on veut les faire
passer pour des violents mais le
problème c'est c'est l'accès à l'eau ça
une seule a été dit
l'alphabétisation le problème des
infrastructures et la guadeloupe de la
guadeloupe n'est pas le seul dans ce cas
le seul le territoire où il ya des
inégalités fortes
nous république souveraine ne défendons
l'égalité et des territoires et une
justice territoriale qui n'existe pas
vous avez des territoires comme mayotte
vous avez des favelas ce en france vous
avez là la guyane vous avez 50 % de
pauvreté et bien c'est inadmissible et
c'est normal que les gens se révoltent
et vous avez aussi comme en guadeloupe
des antilles vax bon ok mais ce n'est
pas le coeur je pense de la
revendication et je rappellerai quand
même monsieur notre grand notre grand
mais scientifique pasteur pasteur disait
vous tombez malade de ce que vous buvez
et je peux comprendre que des citoyens
français qui ont des problèmes d'accès à
l'eau potable trouve étonnant que l'on
veut aussi gentiment s'occuper d'eux sur
certaines maladies alors que toutes les
autres maladies ils les subissent parce
qu'ils n'ont pas accès à l'eau potable
voilà le nous je considère que il faut
résister à ces tentatives de
manipulation du gouvernement qui qui va
s'opérer de cette manière c'est à dire
de mettre le focus que sur les violents
et il dira que le gouvernement et la
belle est bon pour remettre l'ordre
alors vous lisiez il ya effectivement
deux problématiques qui se sont greffés
mais à l'origine des manifestations
c'est donc l'opposition passe sanitaires
et à l'obligation vaccinale une
conséquence directe beaucoup de
soignants absent dans les hôpitaux voyez
l'analyse de jean luc mélenchon
les décisions aberrantes l'indifférence
et les mensonges des autorités laissent
prévoir facilement en explosion qui a eu
lieu tout était prévisible monsieur
macron a choisi de regarder ailleurs et
de laisser la situation dégénérer
telle est la logique de pourrissement et
de diabolisation qui permet ensuite de
justifier une répression féroce alors
jean frédéric poisson tout était
prévisible selon jean luc mélenchon et
en même temps la situation précaire dans
les outre-mer elle existait aussi à
l'heure des quinquennat précédent à ce
que les gouvernements successifs
finalement ont abandonné les outre-mer
selon vous oui très probablement en tout
cas ces gouvernements ne prennent pas la
mesure de l'immense chance que nous
avons en france d'avoir effectivement
des territoires et des départements au
delà de nos mères
sinon s'il entrerait la mesure d'abord s
en occuperait mieux et je partage ce
qu'a dit monsieur cozma de licha
quelques instants en réalité il est
intolérable qui est en france des
bidonvilles les gens qui n'est pas accès
à l'eau potable enfin que ont protesté
de manière véhémente contre ces états de
fait me paraît parfaitement parfaitement
normal qu'on cite je me souviens que
en 2009 lorsque le milieu outre mer yves
jégo nous faisait son rapport de retour
négociations de guadeloupe on se disait
deux choses je suis pas sûr qu'on manque
de tonnerre en guadeloupe parce que
c'est une des grandes revendications des
syndicats locaux dans cette dans ce
conflit je suis pas du tout certain
qu'il soit possible d'arrêter des
licenciements comment longtemps je suis
en revanche tout à fait certain du fait
que le l'installation du pass sanitaire
dans ce territoire comme partout produit
un désordre à la fois inutile et
parfaitement parfaitement insupportable
et deuxièmement je suis parfaitement
certains aussi du fait que sur la
question des prix puisque c'est une
question centrale du cecos 20 2vic je le
rappelais c'est l'exode de 2009 démarre
aussi sur cette question les pouvoirs
d'achat et des prix on n'a pas pris la
peine de s'interroger sur la manière
dont sont faits les prix dans les
départements d'outre-mer la manière dont
l'éloignement renchérit des denrées qui
sont apportées la manière dont sans
doute les circuits de répartition des
richesses localement dans ces
territoires
produit en lui même un certain nombre
d'inégalités qui sont insupportables et
de cela en fait aucun gouvernement tu ne
sais vraiment préoccupé en profondeur et
pour terminer j'ajoute que ce
pourrissement en guadeloupe et une fois
n'est pas coutume je suis d'accord avec
ce qu'en dit jean luc mélenchon
ce pourrissement de la guadeloupe il
rejoint exactement le désintérêt profond
que pendant très longtemps ça a l'air de
changer mais pendant très longtemps le
gouvernement a manifesté à l'égard de la
nouvelle calédonie vous savez qu'il y
aura un référendum dans quelques jours
en nouvelle calédonie de 12 décembre
prochain
enfin le gouvernement a décidé de s'y
intéresser ça n'a pas aidé car pendant
quatre ans le gouvernement s'en était
désintéressé tout autant donc oui nous
avons du mal à comprendre comment
l'outre-mer peu comment dire participer
activement au redressement d'autres pays
visiblement on est en train d'oublier
encore aujourd'hui alors marlène
schiappa s'est défendu en appartenir à
un gouvernement qui a abandonné les
outre-mers écouter
qu'est ce que vous avez apporté à la
guadeloupe qu est-ce qui a changé
beaucoup de choses et je le dis en tant
que personnes d'origine corse et donc
d'une origine insulaire même si la corse
n'est pas comparable aux outre-mer voilà
marlène jusqu'à pas conquis mais c'est
ses origines insulaires en avant pour
groupe défendre
le bilan du gouvernement george smith
masovic votre réaction
vous changez de lire c'est grotesque et
ridicule c'est pas la première fois
qu'elle se
celui d'ecully donc je ne commenterai
pas madame sherpa quoique si en fait
voilà le chat passant pas compte quand
on parle d'une égalité des territoires
on ne parle pas que des outre mer en
fait que ça concerne également la france
ici à 1h30 de paris vous avez le
territoire le bassin minier de lens
voilà c'est tout à fait en france et il
ya
30% de pauvreté dans la ville 30 % de
chômage et
il ya des problèmes d'accès à l'eau
parce qu'il ya des pollutions et les
gens craignent de boire l'eau glacée en
france et la guadeloupe est en france et
malheureusement le fait est que ce
gouvernement de manière générale parce
que il est pris dans des logiques
économiques néolibérales et qu'ils ne
s'intéressent pas à ses citoyens
laisse aller
à continuer à saborder l'hôpital sur
l'ensemble du territoire rappelle quand
même que des milliers de lits ont été
fermés pendant la crise de la colline
qui ne s'intéresse pas au futur de ce
pays puisqu'il a laissé se fermer des
centres de recherche par exemple de
sanofi en pleine crise de lakovic je
prends ces exemples sanitaire parce
qu'on était dans une crise sanitaire
mais est tout nu tout tout tout est dans
le même sens les grandes infrastructures
ne sont pas ne sont pas ne sont pas
réparées ce gouvernement ne s'intéresse
pas à ce pays et suit une logique qui
est la sienne en bout d'un moment la
conséquence et les gens se révoltent
quand légitimement et bien les accès aux
services publics sont mauvais
l'éducation est mauvaise et même l'accès
à l'eau est mauvais comme c'est le cas
en guadeloupe en tous les cas pour être
tout à fait juste avec marlène schiappa
élit ensuite que finalement les mesures
du gouvernement
prise pour la métropole et bien elle
bénéficie aussi aux outre-mer est ce que
jean frédéric poisson vous pensez que
les décisions prises en france
métropolitaine elles sont aussi
applicables en outre-mer ou alors qu'il
faut
une politique qui s'adapte davantage à
ces territoires
si si je suppose que vous faites
référence spécifiquement aux questions
liées à la crise sanitaire
depuis le début de cette crise je
descendis dès que
la une politique sanitaire uniforme
univoque
à la fin du compte qui n'a aucun sens et
qui s'applique de manière
absolument identique dans toutes les
parties du territoire par définition
n'est pas adaptée aux situations locales
à quoi sert-il de confiner par exemple
dans des départements ou d'exiger le
passé leader départements dans lesquels
il n'y a pas de circulation il n'y a pas
de n'y a pas de cas recensés il ya enfin
de le comment dire les taux
à partir desquels on analyse l'état
d'épidémie sont extrêmement favorables
il faut se donner la possibilité de
traiter localement en fonction des
situations qui sont enregistrés sinon
comment dire on pénalise de manière
extrêmement il adapté pour ne pas dire
injuste il partie de la population qui
n'en a pas besoin
si effectivement les données sanitaires
en guadeloupe e
permettait de traiter cette île
autrement que la métropole de l'été il
fallait pas s'en empêcher mais depuis le
début le gouvernement fait deux choses
ils ignorent la diversité des situations
premièrement et deuxièmement il refuse
de s'appuyer sur d'autres compétences
que la sienne propre jeu part du
gouvernement et du pouvoir exécutif
central la manière dont on ignore la la
capacité du tissu associatif de deux dd
de prendre en compte solidairement
comment dire les rencontres les kakis
qui seraient déclarées la manière dont
on peut quand on est un élu local des ce
que j'ai été pendant un quart de siècle
dont je vois bien tous à s'appuyer sur
la générosité des gens simplement pour
aider à traiter ce genre d'épidémie le
gouvernement ait ignoré sa a ignoré les
nerfs pendant très longtemps ignoré les
collectivités locales pendant très
longtemps et a considéré qu' un peu
comme l'eau il pourrait y arriver tout
seul mais zéro n'existe pas il est
regrettable d'ailleurs ils n'arrivent
pas non plus tout seul dans sa villa t
elle hilare un cheval tout ça donc c'est
pas ses bas comprenez même dans des
bandes dessinées dans des fictions les
héros n'existent pas tout seul le
gouvernement n'est pas un héros loin de
là il aurait dû s'appuyer davantage sur
simplement il france très simplement
tout simplement sur des français et
finalement vous puis de refuse à nouveau
et donc ça ne se produit de la colère
aussi délaissé chez les gens mais si on
fait des distinctions entre la métropole
et l'outre-mer est ce que c'est pas le
principe d'égalité qui est bafouée donc
ces cas là où george schultz masovic
si bien sûr mais enfin il ya quand même
une distinction quand vous êtes sur une
île qui loin de la métropole ça entraîne
des conséquences par exemple sur les
prix et donc à ce moment là qui est au
coeur des sourds des révoltes dans les
antilles et dans ce cas là est vraiment
conséquent devrait trouver des solutions
pour subventionner certains prix et
éviter que
on se retrouve dans des situations dans
les situations difficiles je fais quand
même rappeler mais monsieur poisson
l'adducteur la france est à la deuxième
surface maritime mondial ça fait de nous
une grande puissance et pas une petite
puissance dans le contexte de conflits
de guerre de plus en plus qui se
développe pour l'accès aux ressources
c'est un élément de puissance et de
résidences de la france dans les crises
face aux crises qui viennent et cela est
rendu possible possible par toutes ces
îles que nous avons sur l'ensemble de la
planète est bien le minimum c'est de
rendre ce que cette puissance nous offre
aux français qui sont et qui sont sur
ces ide et travailler à l'égalité des
territoires à la justice sociale
économique sur ces territoires je pense
que ce gouvernement ne le fait pas et
encore une fois je répète va pourrir la
situation car il ne voudra pas répondre
à la crise sociale
[Musique]
j'y vois je loue jouer le jeu de la de
la répression en espérant que ils auront
lieu le guide en tirera des bénéfices
pour l'élection présidentielle à venir
de 2022 alors franchement roussel fabien
hausse est donc candidat du parti
communiste français à l'élection
présidentielle et lui est en déplacement
en guyane et puis en martinique 1
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine et lui il
demande un plan d'urgence pour les
territoires d'outre-mer regarder
les besoins sont considérables en
matière de santé publique bien sûr mais
aussi pour tout ce qui concerne les
biens de première nécessité
je sollicite l'examen d'un plan
d'urgence pour les territoires
d'outre-mer à l'image de ce qui vient
d'être décidé pour marseille jean
frédéric poisson applaudi d'urgence à
l'image de marseille est une bonne idée
selon vous
pourquoi pas si c'est nécessaire et si
effectivement les îles des antilles et
les départements antillais outre-mer en
général sont dans un tel état
ma foi il faut effectivement que
l'ensemble des acteurs puisse venir en
aide à la population s'il y en a besoin
je ne suis pas contre les plans
d'urgence par principe je fis sceptique
à l'égard des plans d'urgence quand ils
sont décidés opportunément cinq mois
avant une élection donc je commence à
entretenir de sérieux doutes
deuxièmement je suis sceptique sur la
capacité du trou du gouvernement à
trouver des ressources qu'en fait il ne
dépensera pas parce que beaucoup des
plans d'urgence sont portés aussi par
les collectivités donc ce n'est pas de
budget et a donc mais une fois qu'on a
dit ça peu importe si effectivement
c'est nécessaire à lancy et
effectivement si le système de santé est
dans un tel état qui ne seraient plus
personne elles donnent eux si on est
incapable dans certains coins de de la
guadeloupe d'accéder correctement à une
eau potable une eau qui soit potable et
donc à une alimentation saine avec tout
ce que ça veut dire en terme d'hygiène
ainsi qu'il faisait ce qu'il faut
mais encore une fois ne ne ne
considérons pas que
commentaires que le faisons pas tout
seul une fois encore le l'erreur
consisterait a décidé depuis paris et
même depuis un le triangle d'or parisien
pourrait pierre sinon les deux hectares
et demi de superficie de l'elysée de ce
qu'il faut faire pour dale white blue
quel que soit encore une fois la nature
et le contenu des revendications portées
par les organisations syndicales et
encore une fois il y en a un certain
nombre d'entrées avec elle à titre
personnel en tout cas je ne pourrai pas
être d'accord enfin tout ce qu'elle
demande n'est pas irrecevable loire de
la donc le moindre des choses c'est
d'engager le dialogue avec les gens qui
vous disent on a besoin de parler
parlons alors paraît absolument anormal
de maintenir le silence sur des
revendications certaines sont aussi
importantes que celles il en reste
quelques minutes jordan bardella lui
semblement nationale a comparé la
situation en outre-mer avec celle des
gilets jaunes regarder
emmanuel macron n'a pas compris les
gilets jaunes donc il est difficile pour
lui d'aller comprendre une france qui
vit à dix mille kilomètres
en amont pour conclure georges cusma
dovic finalement les gilet jaune c'est
ce qui se passe en outre mer vous faites
le lien également
mais je les fais tout à l'heure donc oui
un lien et ce lien c'est les problèmes
d'accès aux services publics les
problèmes d'accès aux soins les
problèmes d'accès à une éducation
correcte et et le niveau de vie ce sera
un problème récurrent car c'est un
problème récurrent on est quand même on
a dépassé les 10 millions de pauvres
dans ce pays on a multiplié par deux le
nombre de ceux qui en particulier
étudiants des jeunes qui demandent
l'aide de l'aide alimentaire sous la
présidence emmanuel marc compte il se
gargarise d'être tombé à 7,5 8 % de
chômage mais c'est faux il suffit de ce
bal de se pencher sur les chiffres de
l'insee si on y rajoute le terme de halo
du chômage c'est-à-dire 2 millions de
chômeurs supplémentaires on voit bien
que la situation est difficile et que
parmi ceux qui travaillent un sur cinq
est souvent des femmes sont précaires
longuement ça ne va pas et c'est encore
pire dans les territoires soit dans les
territoires d'outre-mer donc oui
évidemment il y aura des révoltes
sociales mais évidemment si monsieur
emmanuel macron continue à décider seuls
dans des conseils de défense en passant
par dessus tout les compétences qu'elles
soient locales comme l'a dit monsieur
poisson ou ou nationales et qu' ils
préfèrent plutôt que par exemple
d'organiser la distribution des vaccins
de se pencher sur les militaires qui ont
quelques quelques idées en termes de
logistique assez efficace de préférer de
choisir des cabinets de consulting comme
mckinsey eh bien oui ça ça ça se passera
mal et je pense que si ces mckinsey qui
qui conseille le président sur la
manière qu'il faut gérer la crise en
guadeloupe on va vers de gros problèmes
et c'est tragique pour ce territoire
français qui mérite mieux que cette
approche
exclusivement répressive et de laisser
pourrir une situation qui ne méritent
pas on arrive au terme de cet échange un
grand merci à tous deux d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin sur rtl france
merci à vous jean frédéric poisson merci
à vous georges kiejman au beach